we are coming to the end of February
which is Black History Month so I asked
a good friend of the show to come out
and say a few words you know him from
black-ish brownish and his hilarious
Netflix comedy special our friend Deon
Cole let's get him out here
thanks Conan I do want to talk about
Black History Month but what I have to
say is a little confrontational
now it's gonna upset some white people
but I don't want to come off as an angry
black man so instead of me saying what I
want to say I got one of your whitest
writers to speak on my bad
so please welcome my buddy and friend
Brian Kylie come on out
just read what's on the cards Conan you
lazy mother you have the nerve to ask me
Deon Cole to come on the very last show
in the very last week of Black History
Month I guess my job is to add a layer
of blackness to your cracker-ass show
Deon that is not why I asked you here
see I told you it was gonna upset some
white people keep going Brown Conan you
sorry-ass [ __ ]
you treat Black History Month like some
test you didn't study for so you call me
your fly is help black friend Deon Cole
at the last minute to try to make you
look all woken ship okay this is this is
really it's just not true and word
please
[Laughter]
you could have called me much sooner in
February no I couldn't be on the reason
we didn't call you sooner is because we
couldn't come up with a good comedy idea
about the topic that's never stopped you
before mother all right I didn't write
that par Brian just do that
anyway Conan I love you and I love your
show I'm happy to come in and do a Black
History Month bit just don't wait to the
last minute I know I now get in here and
hug a brother
I got this bond I got this
[Music]
everybody
that's Dion on his Cole ology stand-up
tour tickets Deon Cole dot-com be there
[Applause]